today i'm going to share with you a soft
skill an intangible skill that can pay
you a lot of money and not only that can
help you elevate in your life whether
it's business sports politics no matter
what you're doing
simply because this one intangible
skills so let's get right into it so if
this message is something that you need
to hear right now it gives you value
give me a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel but let me get right into it so
imagine you're the ceo of disney okay
your name is bob iger
and you're on your way to go to china
shanghai you're excited because you're
about to open up shanghai disney it's a
big deal it's a park you're fired up
about it's a new market it's a big
market it could do very well for disney
right on your way there you get news
that at orlando
a
kid was attacked by an alligator and the
kid died
and you're in the mood
excited
fired up
expansion in shanghai park mood is great
positive oh my gosh can't wait to go
give this speech in front of everybody
and your guy says um
the parents are on the line
how do you handle that call
i don't think so glad you do that call i
can't need to do that call be careful
with the language and a word to use i
know remember no matter what you say it
will be held against you no i know
remember if you make it seem like it's
our fault we're going to be sued i know
okay you ready for this yeah yeah
okay
here's the call
you get the call and talk to the parents
what do you tell the parents
how do you explain parents
that go to a park that you're the ceo of
the ma the company
and the alligator attacks
and these parents just lost their baby
how do you address that issue
how do you have that conversation with
the mom and dad what do you tell the mom
i am so sorry i understand you don't
understand
how technical is the words you have to
use
i'm sorry for your loss i'm sorry for
your loss how do you say it
hey just want to say real quick before i
jump into this meeting i don't have a
lot of time you can't say i don't have a
lot of time
why do you speak to their parents
actually think about it
so bob iger has that conversation with
the parents it's all over the news
everybody is writing about it and
talking about it on what happened at
this park in orlando
everybody
a few minutes later you have to go hit
the stage
and do the opening for
shanghai disney
the guy that is
the man running shanghai park whispers
to you
please don't bring up what happened in
orlando because it's a downer we're all
excited right now nobody's thinking
about that so you hit the stage
just a few minutes ago
you were giving your condolences to
parents that lost a kid at a park in
orlando
a few minutes later now you got to be
excited and get up and hey how are you
guys we're very excited about this
and maybe your excitement level has to
be a certain level that other people
don't say how do you go from that kind
of a thing that happens and you're so
excited
all of these things are stuff that you
have to be thinking about right how do
you go and give that message
and then you go down as one of the best
ceos disney ever had how do you do that
see that intangible skill set right
there is one of the hardest things
you'll ever have to learn in business in
a life period i call it the switch and
unplug switch and unplug
then
knowing what language to speak in that
setting let me go a little bit deeper
with this and hopefully this makes sense
to you
i'll be on a call and i'm talking to
investors and i know who my investors
are that i'm talking to right my
language on how i'm speaking with
investors
is a different language then i go have a
conversation with my board members these
are people that have already invested
it's a different conversation and when i
go and talk to the bank who has given us
money then the way i go talk to carriers
who are multi-billion dollar companies
that want to give us uh that we're doing
business with that they paid us tens if
not hundreds of millions of dollars in
commissions then i have to go and talk
to my staff at home office how do i
speak to them different language then
let's just say one of these calls goes
very bad absolutely terrible there's a
falling out there's a lot of friction
how do you
switch
and unplug from that bad call and go
into the next call how are you guys
great to talk to you how's everything
how's the wife how's the family how do
you then next then what's the language
when you come oh your wife called your
kid got in trouble in school how do you
talk to the principal how do you talk to
that coach how do you talk to your son
how do you talk to your daughter then
how do you talk to maybe a sibling
there's a falling out how do you talk to
a friend
all of that is one of the hardest things
you'll ever do to learn how to switch
unplug
new language and you speak to that new
audience you don't speak now somebody
says what are you talking about by the
way you do this all the time you just
may not be aware of it imagine you're
going going out with somebody that you
don't care about but you just have a lot
of good time with this person man or
girl it's just like look we're hanging
out just kind of like one of those
things it's a fling but we have fun
you go out
how's dinner when you go out with that
person you know what afterwards you guys
going to be doing what's the
conversation like hey how are you good
everything good okay i'm gonna go watch
you move you're gonna go to the salt
circle yeah let's go okay cool all right
everything good cause i'll see you
versus you go on a date and you actually
like this girl or guy a lot like this is
somebody you may want to bring home
introduce your mom and dad how's your
language with that person slightly
different ain't it why
switch
unplug language
if you're able to learn the ability to
switch unplug and speak the right
language in the right times
you are officially part of a very small
elite community of people
that have what it takes to lead not 50
not hundreds
you have the ability to lead thousands
of people on top of thousands of people
because that is not an easy thing to do
and typically the way you get good at
this
is by being in these types of situat
situations a lot or seeing somebody else
who's going through this and you
actually witness them doing it then you
say okay i can probably learn that skill
set a lot by the way this doesn't pay a
hundred thousand dollars this doesn't
pay million dollars this is there is no
pick any senior title you want you can
go all the way to the highest level if
you learn how to do this exact thing
that we just talked about in this video
today if this video brought you value
give me a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel and if you want to go a little
bit deeper on this topic i got two other
videos i want you to watch
one of them is seven audiences every ceo
has to deal with what are those
audiences click over here that's what
you want to know the other one is 9 love
languages every entrepreneur must learn
how to speak click your whichever one
you want to watch click on it but
regardless have a great day everybody
take care bye
[Music]
you